yeah he sort of is the founding father
of physics basically so you can't really
get much bigger deal than that for a
physicist or an astronomer he really was
the man who invented the whole subject
uh he's a big deal because he's the
first person to actually use mathematics
and develop mathematics so that you
could create a theory work out the
consequences and compare with experiment
so for example his three laws can be
expressed mathematically turned into
equations and then you find out that the
planets go round in ellipses with the
sun one of the focuses foci of the of
the ellipse sir isaac newton is thought
to be one of the greatest scientists of
all time has contributed a lot to the
field
he developed calculus he
invented a reflecting telescope that was
made from a mirror instead of a lens uh
he's sometimes credited with having
invented the reflecting telescope which
isn't true in fact lots of people have
sort of played around with them even
galileo the first person to use one
astronomically
had actually played around trying to
make telescopes out of mirrors but but
newton's great genius is that he
actually built a practical one one that
actually worked what newton did was
incredible
and
a lot of the things that he came up with
the basis of understanding for example
when he was a student
he there were light beams going through
the shutters of his window and he put it
through a prism and showed that light
split into the spectrum and as a result
of that he could explain why rainbows
came about
and he was able to turn the mathematics
and do the experiments so as to analyze
the natural world in a way nobody had
done before but he was a bit of a
strange character he wasn't an extrovert
he didn't really get along with people
very well i've read that he had a couple
of nervous breakdowns he was a very very
sensitive person so when the calculus is
mathematics came up he and leibniz both
invented complementary aspects
to it and they didn't he couldn't see
that leibniz works on the integral
calculus was complementary to his work
on the differential calculus uh
he he just wanted to rubbish leibniz all
his life
and so it was a competition and he was
very arrogant and aggressive about
things like that
also with robert hook who was a
wonderful experimentalist and wrote the
standard treatise on optics he was an
enemy as far as as uh newton was
concerned and he would try to do
anything to damage hook's reputation so
he he wasn't wouldn't be the nice
colleague to have one of the things that
newton is most famous for um is saying
that you know if he's seen further than
anybody else it was only because he was
standing on the shoulders of giants and
this was always viewed as a kind of
self-deprecating remark that he was
actually you know showing respect to
those who had come before him
more recently it's been suggested
actually he was just having a go at hook
who was famously very short
and so
there are aspects of him he was a little
bit strange he was not necessarily a
particularly nice man he was incredibly
secretive he would keep stuff hidden
away for years and years just because he
was afraid that other people were going
to steal his ideas
but he was a scientist through and
through and he used himself to
experiment with a lot of different
projects so when he was working with
lenses and mirrors and optics he
actually wondered why our eyes are such
sophisticated lenses and so he actually
took an ice pick and kind of probed
behind his eye to figure out how it
worked and so well it's kind of gross i
hate that story
isaac newton is a fascinating character
because
he's famous for writing the principia
mathematica
which certainly changed the face of
physics
but
newton wrote more about theology and
prophecy and alchemy than he ever did
about science and mathematics and
that's extraordinary thing and newton
had some very very eccentric
theological views views about
christianity
isaac newton also liked
to look at the sun to see
how that affected your eyes so of course
as children we all hear don't look at
the sun too long because you'll go blind
well he did actually look at the sun for
quite a long time and then he remarked
in his journal that he saw the image of
the sun in his eye while he was sleeping
rightly was going to sleep even for
about three days so it definitely does
damage to your eye believe it
but newton also rejected the traditional
christian view that
god is not just an individual but god is
a community of
father son and holy spirit
and we call that the trinity three
persons in one god
and
newton rejected
the the view of the church that god is
trinity
it's ironic because newton was a fellow
of trinity college cambridge so
in his very working environment the
institution that he worked for was
dedicated to a doctrine a teaching in
which he himself did not believe well
when i first came to nottingham
i lived way out in lincolnshire and
somebody told us that his house that was
at woolsthorpe near colsterworth and we
drove out there and i got the wrong wall
sort there are two out there
eventually we found the right one and
there in those days this is over 30
years ago
it was
the house was owned by somebody and and
you had to go at a certain time and
she'd open the door for you you can go
around and see all the traces he left
behind because he got his compasses and
scratched pictures of the cathedral in
grantham on the wall so i remember that
vividly gradually this
aura came to settle around newton that
he was
the holder of secrets and that the
principia was as it were
this was newton's scripture
and uh newton himself fostered this
this reputation for being some sort of
prophet of god
and
he did write under some pseudonyms one
of which was
the pseudonym jehovah sanctus eunis
jehovah the the name of god the holy one
which he believed was an anagram of the
latin version of his own name isaacus
newtonis
i thought a manor house would be a big
elizabethan manor but it's actually a
small pokey little place it's not much
bigger than an ordinary semi
only on one floor or maybe two floors it
wasn't that grand i mean think of the da
vinci code today and dan brown i mean
there's nothing new in all that is this
is there something we're not being told
it's a bit like a conspiracy theory
and can we get underneath it all and
just as newton thought that he was
trying to
decode the universe the mind of god by
this mathematics
so he thought that there were all other
codes all over the place including his
own name and anagrams that needed
decoding to see what they revealed so
knowledge had to be prized prized open
to get the secrets and only the very
clever
only only the wise uh could really find
out exactly what was going on in the
mind of god he was you know he he had
the all the trappings of a genius in the
sense that as well as being incredibly
smart and coming up with incredibly
innovative ideas um he also clearly had
his eccentricities as well would you
give him a job here
uh i thought um that's a good question i
wonder how you would succeed in in the
in
academia today
i don't know it's the short answer
a lot of the things that that you know
these eccentricities the the way he
tended to rub people up the wrong way
the fact that he didn't publish things
he hid them away for years at a time you
know in academia today the way you
succeed is by getting your ideas out
there and by publishing things and
showing you know showing your your peers
your fellow scientists what you're doing
um and his approach to science of
keeping stuff very much to himself and
not wanting to share it with people
really wouldn't work terribly well in
the way that science works today he was
really quite phenomenal in his prime and
later on he dabbled in alchemy and all
sorts of things and got into religious
arguments he was a very strange and
complicated person not the sort that you
want to go down the pub with
i'd go to the pub with him
and then you'd start arguing in your
australian way to see to wind him up and
see what you get out of him so you could
do a video for 60 symbols if i could
make a video of isaiah newton roger i
wouldn't be sitting here with you
quite